it's time for roses and Rosie you guys
I'm dressed like the ocean hi everybody
I'm Lauren Zima and we are here to
discuss the first episode of this season
of bachelor in paradise that wasn't
about this scandal it was still
mentioned a little bit but not a ton
okay so I thought that this top would be
perfect for Rosen as a bachelor in
paradise because again wait am moving
around and also a little shoulder cut
out those bachelor gals love these tops
they love them I'm one of them
I'm not we also have the Paradise night
sky really getting our color coordinated
Genesis I love it
okay let's dive right in with a red solo
cup of rose a because let's face it hon
bachelor in paradise season 4 episode 3
they were finally here to party a party
sorry I'm so hungover for my night of
partying in paradise
not really okay mm I know sending my
notes I forgot about my nose alright so
a lot of this episode was about how the
guys were all about bro time which was
kind of hilarious
and again one thing I love about
donation shows is that real friendships
come out of them and also it kinda heard
that on the DL from the guys that the
reason I hung out with each other so
much was because we'll have the girls
win to Curtis his boyfriend drink every
time we get some scoop that was from
Vinny and Daniel you can check out my
interview them over at EJ online.com my
shameless plug already everybody and I
spill to myself well a lots happening in
the first two minutes this week not a
lot happened in this whole episode but
it was still fun
so Adam gets there and everybody's so
excited to see Adam bros love bros G's
love to everybody else AB give me some
like direction here please Adam loves
Raven Raven I have been getting along
great I'm about to swoop in and take her
away this was part of the time when the
scene was ended a little bit I met
in Dallas during our soui titus from the
show and I really like them I like that
honesty thank you that's the kind of
realness we need on a reality show
after talking to you I was like this
girl is Joe and I got him I'm seeing
this nice using the school and Raven
once again called out Robby scannable
area okay before - well major honestly
they drink every time there was bro time
yeah so many dudes together in a hot tub
not that I'm complaining about that site
okay um so you know Adams like I'm just
going to make my rounds it's going to go
around I'm just going to holler everyone
which is so weird about paradise but he
ends up with Raven great I like them
together you ready for this I'm ready
let me know if you do what do you think
Adam and Raven do they have longevity I
do drink to it and then dudes are laying
on a bed together now another issue
we're having is the Christina seems very
attached to Dean because they hung out
during the shutdown they like one to
Kentucky together not clear on why of
all the places you could go I'm just
saying of all the places no offense
Cosette but of all the places anyway so
Dean is like ass bleep and Christina
goes and wakes him up to VTR I want to
be there for him I do want to see the
potential I don't think you should ever
wake up anyone to have that talks and
Dean's like groans oh and look I look
like which okay Dean okay
but this is one of like many DVR combos
that christina has during this episode
drink every time they tried to finally
show ie
honestly don't know where I sing and
it's never clear it is unclear as dirty
hot tub water which a little scoop dance
has told me that the hot tub and paratus
is disgusting because crap died in it
so they get in there there's dead crabs
floating around inside scoop you can
check out that interview we're at EP
online.com everybody this is why I'm
here to party this week a whole red solo
cup full of Rose Bay okay rosy lips
really all day we have all day and beer
dose drink
alright back to the episode jack doan
Jack stone says some stone cold about
Dean he says he's great if you are in
middle school but not if you're actually
an adult with a career but that was
serious and I mean everybody is there
kind of Colin Dean out this whole
episode here's the thing I think on
Paradise you go there to meet a lot of
people it's not only like the bachelor
bachelorette but what one Twitter user
pointed out to me his name I forget but
it was a good point is the Dean and
Christina did have this time together in
Kentucky so like she's pretty attached
and kind of how they were gonna be
together no seemingly they're not ensue
yeah you know drink every time there's a
weird outfit Vinnie says he's wearing
his lucky rose shirt and he when did
that shirt ever bring you in a book and
it didn't tonight either because he got
sent home with the first rose ceremony
of the season hopefully it just helps
because it's not I'm gonna head walking
out this on any was a lariat the
hilarious trying to get a sleep up on
Gaspar
I love Benny and I want love for Vinny
the man cannot find love and he is still
great he is the hardest-working man in
bachelor nation you check his Instagram
there are so many posters for different
DJ gigs with random girls in saw
on those posters to your fortress card
cheers for Benny Robby's wearing that
green bowtie Amanda looks flawless
blaah list her about some paradise
fashion game is on point and how it's
her hair so smooth and that humidity
I've been there I was putting lotion on
my hair to try to keep it down down
there it's crazy
let me take your socks off yeah that had
to be the moment that Robbie knew this
was real because I mean they're like Kim
and Kanye it's like they both care about
fashion and how they look and they're
together Demario City when Colonel were
interested in Brad I can really pan out
I'm going to say Robbie and Amanda are
Kim and Kanye right now a bachelor
nation they're looking good and they're
good together I'm in pretty sure based
on Instagram they were in Cabo together
last weekend the same drink for scoop
[Music]
again how but if I get Instagram if I
look at Instagram he's on the ramp oh
paradise that was almost as gross as
Josh Murray when he was really sweaty
Amanda and Robbie kind of rang up Josh
Moran I guess for all these friends of
him so he wants to call anonymous it's
like someone you're talking about and
then Amanda points out that Robbie's cut
wedding that's like ironic callback
anyway let's move past into that moment
where is Alex W he's been gone this
whole first hour this episode but
doesn't matter because then he goes home
and then the episode got really hard to
watch because of like I don't know
basketball or something and then like a
speech from President Trump and back to
our regularly scheduled programming
okay back to Dean and Kristina D and I
was confused about Dean in this episode
because on the one hand he's being
really honest with Kristina he's like we
jumped into things too soon and on the
other hand he's being I don't know it's
not very bad for like Christina still
gives a rose to Dean because she's
holding on to hope like we were all
holding on to that eclipse being the one
good thing in everybody's life today yep
don't look right at it and don't look at
this catastrophe that's coming
and don't look at Robbie's bowtie it's
so great on the ocean swallowing up all
the drama okay Ben Zorn suspended the
episode talking about a dog and working
out on the beach then sore and get it
like sore he looks good
okay so then Danielle Lombard gets here
I don't know if anyone knows this but
sometimes when your birthday falls
between two major holidays it's hard to
celebrate it and we see more of being
seen with his commentary yeah but
they're all like oh my god she's so hot
and Adams like she's like a glass of
wine maybe I'll take that out I'll take
it now alexis is not happy with Dean
drink every time Alexis calls out D I
don't know who's Dean thinks he is at
this claim huh
yeah I license crack me up she's
hilarious
when I first met Alexis at Nick vials
women tell all she told me she was cast
on The Bachelor just to wise up on
paradise and I said she felt oh and
speaking of Nick vile Alexis said this
here we are walking back to I'm tired I
had the Saracen that I think character
Jenna Heather was known as the
villainous Camacho with the divider one
so in my opinion what might have been
the worst battle in history
hilarious she keeps it real I just love
it in that hot tub full of dead crab so
Dean and like again he's honest he's
like look I really think Danielle's hot
we gotta go on his date to see if
there's more than a physical connection
Danielle came in she had a date card and
she took scene and Christina wasn't
happy about that I don't know I sent
some girl code breakage here maybe I'm
not really sure how close they were
before at the show started or supposed
to get Danielle in here this week to
talk about it
so alexis is like I don't know who Dean
thinks he is at this point and then
and then Dean says something that is
borderline unforgivable
she's not happy about the date with
Danielle she left her I guess emotions
get the best of her a lot of times you
are digging yourself deeper Dean digging
Dean digging Dean you're digging
yourself deeper Dean digging a grave she
lets her emotions get the best of her
first of all I don't I found a little
bit sexist and second of all that's what
the show is about Dean is like your
emotions get the best of you okay you're
there for we want to watch okay but then
what's mind-boggling is deemed charms
Christina back again and she's back in
his folds again in the folds of beans
hair and his doobie smile her to that I
don't know it's confusing and so once
again everyone's like what are you doing
Dean and that's the question we all have
to ask ourselves I mean is Dean Bachelor
material Daniel and Minnie told me that
they thought after Paradise we would not
feel that way okay everybody so that was
this week's episode of bachelor in
paradise
Lacey and Diggy and a gear still there
lots of people are still there the
question is who do you think is going to
make it I believe in Derek and Taylor I
really do they seem on it I would love
to know what you guys think at this
point is it Dean for Bachelor is it
Peter Krause for bachelor who is your
pick you know mine Peter Peter Peter
paid up but Peter I tweeted it Mike
Fleiss about this
don't let this fall through the cracks
Mike Fleiss make your preference I'm
gonna learn it I've been through the
sandal I've been through the most raw
emotional real breakup I've ever seen on
The Bachelorette it's too much if Peter
not the bachelor I don't I'm good at
2017 I'm losing it in 2017 okay okay I'm
wearing a shirt to look like notion I'm
losing it
oh here's to looks okay if I steal
Washington Baldy let's down the rest of
this Solo Cup and cheers - Alexis waters
because what a champion I don't think
she's really dating anyone her and Jack
stone had like a friendship moment and
she gave him her rose and God they sound
like spies together
Alexis waters and Jax tell starring in
Paradise Lost that's the movie I'd say
cheers to them guys like et on Facebook
subscribe to us on YouTube you can
follow me on social media have a great
night and you don't pick yourself into a
hole
[Music]
go I wish this Colt
skid bucket with full Rosie it's not
what they intended this children's toy
for but that's a good size that's more
than a bottle probably